[Music]
i'm
wide open here like i didn't say that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you do that mostly
[Music]
um
oh
i don't even know
[Music]
thank you
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
as much as it could be
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
please
[Music]
somebody
[Music]
hey
[Music]
oh
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
allison
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone it is my honor and
privilege to introduce our next vice
president senator kamala harris
senator harris grew up believing in the
promise of america
and fights every day to ensure that
promise is fulfilled for all americans
she started fighting for working
families in the alameda county district
attorney's office
and from there she became the first
black woman elected as san francisco's
district attorney
in 2010 she made history again by
becoming the first black woman to be
elected
attorney general of california
overseeing the country's second largest
justice department
where she continued to fight for
families the lgbtq community
student borrowers and our environment
since joining the senate in 2016 senator
harris has continued her fight for all
americans
as a member of three powerful committees
intelligence
judiciary and homeland security and
governmental affairs
senator harris graduated from howard
university
where she was in the alpha kappa alpha
sorority
and earned her law degree from uc
hastings college of law
she continues to fight for all of us
break glass ceilings and make history as
the first black woman
to be on a presidential ticket
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please give a warm
welcome to senator kamala harris
can we hear it for allison
[Applause]
i love our young leaders i love our
young leaders alison is a junior
we were talking about she's studying
interdisciplinary
studies and we were talking about you
know it's it's a challenging time
for everyone and for our students our
daughter is a senior in college
and so it's just it it really
pardoned my expression sucks um but
allison you're amazing
and i'm so happy to share the stage with
you thank you again let's hear it for
you
[Applause]
i asked bill how does everybody
hi hi it's so good to be with you guys
you know mayor i want to thank you
i just for all that we were supposed to
be here
last week and it was so important that
we we came and so we recreated the
schedule
to be with you but i want to thank the
mayor in front of everybody
for the work that you've been doing both
as a leader here in nashville but in
north carolina and also
in the support that you've given for joe
biden and myself so thank you if we can
hear it
and the chancellor who is here and who
gave me such a wonderful and warm
welcome
thank you for all that you do in just
nurturing and growing the minds of our
incredible future and current leaders
thank you
thank you and to the members of the
north carolina general assembly i want
to thank you all for your leadership and
what you're doing
um we have the chief of the eastern band
of cherokee indians richard sneed
i want to thank him i'm going to thank
the
county commissioners and city council
the uh buncombe county sheriff quinton
miller
and all of you thank you
so um so much to talk about and i'm just
going to
move this there so i can see you guys um
13 days to go 13 days to go
and we cannot spare a minute sister
and brothers we cannot spare a minute
in terms of everything that i know
everyone here and around our country
is prepared to do as joe biden says to
fight for the soul
of our nation and that's really what
what's going on right it's about
fighting for the soul of our nation it's
about knowing
we deserve more and we are better than
this
and there's so much that happened even
before
kovitz struck but in many ways i've
thought of this pandemic as being an
accelerator
in that it has highlighted what was
wrong before
and it has made it worse right
and so let's think about it in the
context of
what has been going on in terms of
public health especially during this
virus and we can't overlook the fact
that on january 28th donald trump and
mike pence were informed
about the nature of covid19 this virus
they were informed five times more
likely to kill people than the flu
informed it could harm children informed
it is
airborne can you imagine
what the families of asheville with the
families of north carolina could have
done with that information
on that date to prepare
be it to stock up on toilet paper
or or to plan because we know that the
vast majority of americans
don't have more than a thousand dollars
in savings
and what folks might have done to
prepare knowing that it's
predictable that they may not be able to
go to work for a while
and sadly we still have so many workers
in america who don't have paid sick
leave and paid family leave
but he didn't tell us they sat on that
information they covered it up
and instead the president of the united
states the commander-in-chief
whose first responsibility should be to
keep the american people safe
set on this information and suggest it
to the american people you're on one
side of his ledger if you don't wear a
mask
and on the other side of his ledger if
you do
and now we're looking at a situation
where over 220
000 americans have lost their lives in
just the last
several months many of whom
have families and they could not even
see them
and hold their hands and touch them
in their last days on this earth
we now have a situation where over 8
million people have contracted this
virus having untold
long-term health consequences including
what doctors are telling us lung
scarring things of that nature
and in the midst of all of this the
public health crisis
you've got donald trump and his boy bill
barr
in the united states supreme court this
is stranger than fiction have you ever
heard that that expression fact is
stranger than fiction
we're living it we're living it sister
and so what are we seeing right now in
the midst of a public health pandemic
donald trump and bill barr are in the
united states supreme court
trying to get rid of the affordable care
act that president obama and vice
president biden
[Applause]
[Music]
made it happen that brought health care
to over 20
million americans and if they are
successful
it is estimated at least 23 million
americans will lose their coverage
you know there's this weird thing i
think actually about
couple but this thing about donald trump
this weird thing
he's got this weird obsession
with wanting to get rid of whatever
president obama and vice president biden
created and it's just this weird
obsession
right so the other thing is that if he's
successful
in getting rid of the affordable care
act remember
it put in place protections for people
with pre-existing conditions
if you know anybody who has diabetes
asthma high blood pressure breast cancer
and now we're talking about 8 million
people who have a pre-existing condition
called covet
and they're trying to get rid of it that
alone is reason to know
that he is incapable of being a
president
who will protect the well-being and
health of the american people
and that's why he's got to go
[Applause]
we're looking at a situation again
this pandemic has been an accelerator
we're looking at a situation where over
30 million americans had to apply
for unemployment insurance many of whom
again did not have paid sick leave
did not have paid family leave
and and and they're trying to push
through a supreme court nominee
in what i call an illegitimate process
because by the way we're not talking
about election season
we're not talking about election year
we're talking about an election
that is taking place right now where
over 20 million americans have voted
and the election will be over in 13 days
and the majority of the american people
are saying
let the american people decide who will
be their president
and then that is the person who should
decide who will fill
a lifetime appointment to the highest
court in our land
[Music]
but yet they're trying to push through
this nomination i serve as
allison told you on the judiciary
committee i will say publicly i
i will oppose her confirmation
for a number of reasons that include the
illegitimacy of the process
that include the right of women to make
decisions about their own body and their
own reproductive health care
that include the need to maintain the
affordable care act
but they're pushing this thing through
now
while there is a bill
sitting on a desk that's been sitting
there for 150 days
called the heroes act that would bring
relief to
all of these people who are suffering
right now who are in
food lines for hours the one in
five mothers in america who is
describing her children
under the age of 12 is being hungry
who need an expansion of what we're
fighting for in that bill
snap benefits you know what that is we
used to call it food stamps
it's what people need when they're
hungry
[Applause]
but they're pushing through this
nomination instead of the senate
republicans saying vote on that bill
including one senator from this state
[Music]
do you know what i'm talking about so
this is what we're seeing and this is
why we need joe biden
to be elected press in the united states
because on the one hand you have
joe biden who was one of the
creators and one of the reasons that we
have the affordable care act
who will make a commitment has made a
commitment to you
north carolina and the american public
that he will expand
coverage that he will expand health care
bring down the cost of premiums
bring down the cost of prescription
drugs lower medicare
eligibility to age 60. he is saying i
will expand health care understanding
for too long we've been pretending
health care is about a body that starts
from the neck down but we need to also
deal with healthcare from the neck up
that's called mental healthcare
and on the other hand you have donald
trump who's trying to get rid of it
on the one hand you have joe biden who
says you want to talk about how we
measure the success of the economy
well we measure the success of the
economy based on the health and
well-being of working families in
america
on the other hand you have donald trump
who passed the tax bill benefiting the
top one percent and the biggest
corporations of america
which will lead to a two trillion dollar
deficit joe biden is saying i'm not
going to raise taxes on anybody who
makes less than four hundred thousand
dollars a year
he's saying i'm going to make sure first
time home buyers get a 15 000
tax credit to help them with down
payments and closing costs knowing that
homeownership
is one of the greatest ways that you
create wealth in american families
on the one hand you have a joe biden who
says
we've got to deal with supporting the
public schools of america
and we will triple title one funding for
those schools
that are in the highest needs
communities with the lowest tax base
because the children of those
communities have a god-given capacity
to be nurtured and to thrive but we need
to give them the resources
on the other hand you have a donald
trump who put betsy devos in
office on the one hand you have
a donald trump who
has been rejecting science from day one
rejecting science on the issue of this
climate crisis
which is threatening our very existence
rejecting science on the issue of this
virus and on the other hand you have a
joe biden
who embraces science who
will be a leader who says that the
public health experts
must guide the policy decisions we make
on
all of these issues that literally
threaten the health and well-being of
the american people
so there are very clear choices here
and the bottom line is i do believe
the outcome of this race will in very
many ways
be decided by you north carolina
it will be and in that way the choices
and the decisions you are making will
impact people around the country
in that way what you are doing to vote
and vote early is going to impact
people that you may never meet and
people
who may never know your name but whose
life
will forever be changed because of what
you are doing
and so i'm here in north carolina 13
days back in north carolina
but 13 days before this election to
thank you
for what you all have already done and
what you're committed to do
and this issue before us of who will be
the next president united states
has everything to do with fixing the
problems
but it also has to do with restoring
in our country what we know to be our
highest
ideals around unity
around bringing folks together around
rejecting these notions of fear and hate
and division
of doing what we know we have had the
capacity and have the capacity to do
to regain our standing in a way we can
feel
good about the future of our children
and
our nation all of this is at stake right
now
and joe and i are actually particularly
proud i'm proud i was doing some
interviews earlier
we're proud of the fact that ours is a
campaign that has probably built one of
the broadest coalitions
of any campaign in recent history
we've got the support yes of democrats
and republicans and independents
people of all walks of life all races
right because we know that
to strengthen our country to take back
the soul of our country it's about all
of us
and all of us being a part of where we
go and where we need to go and where we
can go so i want to thank you asheville
for all that you were doing 13 days to
go
we don't want to look back in 14 days
and have any regrets
you know and i guess my last point is
this
this moment will pass
and years from now our children our
grandchildren others
they're going to look at us they're
going to look in our eyes every one of
us and they will
ask us where were you
at that moment and here's the thing
what we will be able to tell them is
more
than just how we felt we will tell them
what we did we will tell them we were
hanging out in this parking lot in
nashville
with the mayor and all these incredible
friends and neighbors and we will tell
them how we
organized how we made sure that people
know what's at stake
how we reminded people that none of us
is alone we're all in this together
and we will tell them about what we did
to fight for the soul of our nation
thank you all
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay guys
none of these people are are we ready
are we set
we can go ahead and start
all right you're right in the line of my
voice
keep to the right
just go to the business
oh it's leaking the ac
oh the air conditioner
has removed
i don't think anyone's sitting there
um
on the schedule as
145.45 but we will probably be
closer
one yeah
uh
[ __ ]
[Music]
buddy
right
you know
um
you